the 62nd annual Academy Awards is being
brought to you by today's Chevrolet who
invites you to see my nobody's winning
like the heartbeat of America
the Prudential come to the companies of
the Prudential and build your future on
the rock strike the only soft drink of a
great taste of Lyman that unexpected
twist makes us special
and the new a TMT Universal card one
world one car
here to present the award for
live-action short films please welcome
the stars from two summer blockbusters
from Honey I Shrunk the Kids and Uncle
Buck Rick Moranis and John Candy
we're here to present the Oscar for the
Best Motion Picture under 10 minutes
short short film and this is a right
category for us John because we've both
been in a couple of films that could
have been shorter well a couple maybe
well let's get let's get right to it
here we go the nominees for best
achievement in live-action short films
are Amazon Diary Robert Nixon
the child either Jonathan Tammuz
work-experience James Hendry go here we
go the Oscar goes to work experience
James Henry
well having been advised not to thank
lots of people I'm going to thank lots
of people I'd like to thank Robin vision
I Center for cinematographer produce a
Mary Bell British screen and channel for
and Lenny Henry most of all and thank
you the Academy
to present the award for best
achievement in animated short films
celebrating his 50th anniversary in show
business the oldest fur coat in
Hollywood Bugs Bunny folks the Academy's
been nice enough to ask me to present
the nominees for Best Animated Short
subject but what's animation anyway
dad's animation in animation anything
can happen and you expect the unexpected
how's this for splitting hairs is all so
it can be in sense of gravity and let's
see De Niro try this but the best part
of being animated is I'm never
unemployed and from the looks of it
these nominees won't be either
the nominees are balance Kristoff
Lowenstein and Wolfgang Lowenstein the
cow Alexander Petrov the hill farm mark
Baker the envelope please and the winner
is balance Christoph Lowenstein and
Wolfgang Lowenstein
you
so what could I say it's very exciting
to be here in LA on this stage with this
great guy we want to thank the Academy
Terry thorne who brought us to America
and many friends in Germany who had us
for example what reason my teacher who
is one of the greatest artists in
animation film thank you very much
that's what I wanted to say to thank
bugs is 50th anniversary it's amazing he
looks good he had minor surgery - did
you know that bugs
he had his prostate erased